one hello hello even dad is here to celebrate for the
countdown oh my god i can't believe you're so close to 900k
subscribers oh my god i'm i'm so thankful for you guys thank
you guys i was debating whether or not to stream today uh
because you know like it's sunday sunday isn't stream day
sunday is usually not stream day so i was like debating
whether or not i was like oh but then it's 900k i was like
okay we're gonna i'm gonna so i was like um i'm gonna wait
until we're really really close and then and then i do the
stream i i do the stream because i couldn't tell because i
was like oh i don't know what if it's like it would be like
oh it's close but like I need it to be close close because
I'm like thinking what if it takes me like five hours to do
the final stretch I was like I can't do that like I'm going
to the Christmas market tomorrow I can't fucking do that I
can't I was just like I'm just gonna you know I'm just gonna
go work a little bit um um I need I'm gonna go work a little
bit and then uh play like two to three rivals games And
then, you know, maybe do the stream.
I then proceeded to play Marvel Rivals for...
Six hours?
And I went up two games!
Yeah, baby!
I was up two games a point!
Yay!
Please don't tell my manager I didn't do any work today.
I was like, I'll just play two games.
to three games what's the worst that could happen six hours
later i i did not rank up like i said i was only up two
games oh thank you for the five gift of ships thank you
thank you almost there we're almost there oh my god we're
almost there guys oh my god i can't wait i can't wait to see
it That's a lot of dragons that's like we can be like a
small country With that amount of numbers Jakarta they give
it oh shit whoops whoops Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, okay.
We're just gonna look I don't I'm just worried.
I'm gonna okay.
It's it.
Yeah, sorry I accidentally moved it, but I'm scared to move
move it anymore because what if we hit 900,000 and then I
scrolled up Oh my god And!
Boom, boom, boom, beep,
it is.
Wait, I'm just end stream.
No, I'm not going to end stream.
I'm not going to end stream.
I will hang out a little bit.
And boom, we did it.
Happy New Year.
Speed run.
I was here.
We did it.
We finished counting.
Stream end.
Oh, my God.
Thank you, everyone.
We're not getting 1 million tonight, guys.
You guys are very confident.
but I don't think that's possible.
Jakarta, thank you for the 10, thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you.
We're nearing 900K, so congratulations, Tokyo.
How crazy time flies.
That Marvel Rivals hit over the holiday break for real.
Thanks for celebrating with the stream, thank you, thank you
for the super chat, Jakarta, thank you, thank you.
Juan George, thank you for the super, thank you, thank you.
Pretty congratulations for 900K, so happy for you.
Now I'm going to pass out, got to work tomorrow.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
a million thank you for the five gifts thank you thank you a
case thank you for the for the super thank you thank you 900
oh my god thank you everyone 900 8k congrats toky thank you
guys we thank you for the aca super thank you thank you
congrats to keep so glad to see you become such a successful
youtuber a good time to be a dragon thank you thank you
thank you the aca super thank you thank you so for the 900k
celebration I know we sort of like haven't done the 800k
celebration yet we're gonna go backwards okay I gotta do the
9k celebration first and then we'll do the 800k celebration
we are a bit late just a little bit late for the 800k
celebration but um I do have plans for the 900k because that
one was like 900 was a bit closer to a million so uh for uh
900k uh subscribers um I'm combining the christmas stream
with the 900k subscriber celebration so it's gonna be a it's
gonna be a packed event it's gonna be a bit packed so what i
have planned for 900k will be um combined with the christmas
stream um for the oh oh yeah but then people are like turkey
uh oh wait should i do it for the christmas maybe christmas
eve okay i'm debating about this because i'm like wait some
you guys have real lives every guy not everyone like i don't
sell i you know i i obviously i don't have a life so that's
why i stream on christmas so i that's what i'm thinking um
oh my gosh maybe i'm like thinking do i do a christmas or i
combine it with the okay i'll do it at christmas eve i think
like christmas eve some of you guys can skip christmas eve
right like or maybe 20 there's no way all right there's no
way anyone does anything on the 27th uh christmas eve it is
more okay wait what about all right how about the day after
christmas the day after okay the either the day after
christmas or the 26th or boxing day you guys don't need to
participate on boxing day just shop online like like uh like
black friday all right either we do boxing day or the 27th
because the 27th nothing happens on the 27th uh 26 or 27th
guys what's boxing day i think that's like uh i think that's
like a i was gonna say it's a thing for any country that's
been uh that's been colonized by europe by the uk
by the UK has boxing day I'm pretty sure because I know
Australia has boxing day so all right I see more people on
the 27th than the 26th okay 27th will be the 900k
celebration okay now I gotta figure out what to do on
Christmas then not all right I'm about to okay now that a
huge chunk of my Planned Christmas stream is being moved to
the 27th.
I shall now try to figure out what to replace it with on
Christmas.
Oh yeah, we'll do an 800k celebration on Christmas.
You know, you're right.
That's actually pretty good.
All right, 800, I'll do like 800k celebration.
And because we were supposed to play the climbing game.
We're supposed to beat the climbing game.
So 800k, that was the climbing game, right?
That was for 800k.
I don't remember, right?
So, so we'll do that.
We'll do the 800K celebration, and then we'll go straight to
the 900K celebration on the 27th.
And then, and then there's New Year.
There is like, it's like our own little special Christmas
week.
The United States does not celebrate boxing with exceptions
of Massachusetts.
Patrick Webster, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You would, I feel like we all know why the U.S.
doesn't celebrate.
boxing.
I think they're trying, you know, they're like, oh, we don't
want to be like, like the UK, you know, they're like the
rebellious son, like, oh, gross.
That's gross, dad.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Boxing tuber for 2025 for boxing.
Hey, and then give it a super chat, Jack.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for all the love, guys.
I really do appreciate.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, anyway, I forgot to say it.
Big announcement, guys.
Huge announcement.
Don't worry.
Let me grab the image real quick.
For those who don't know, huge, very important announcement
I have to make before we begin.
Fortnite updated.
uh um fortnite updated their shop today uh with new skins
and it's batman beyond guys oh my god they added batman
beyond to fortnite no i know i did have sponge up but no
this is very important not only did they added sponge bomb
to fortnite but now we got batman beyond no way you can the
glider from batman beyond you can use the glider in fortnite
return of the joker my heart um but yes remember to use my
critical dokey bird if you want to do you want to buy i'm
gonna guys i spent 60 the last two days i've yet to buy the
batman bundle but i logged into fortnite this is legit very
big news um but i logged into fortnite yesterday I could
buy, I bought the entire SpongeBob pack, so for the
SpongeBob pack I got SpongeBob as a companion, but like also
I got the, his like little um, his little like uh, uh what
is it?
Oh my gosh, what's the backpack is?
Meow meow meow meow.
Doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
I got doo-doo-doo-Bob, but the one thing I was really
looking forward to, you know how SpongeBob did a collab with
Crocs?
And has anyone seen the Squidward Crocs?
Oh, my...
I bought the Squidward Crocs.
Let me...
Oh, yeah, and it comes with the jellyfish dance, too.
That one was also very important.
I need you guys to see...
I actually want to buy this IRL.
Why not fucking wear this in real life?
I...
You think anyone would judge me if I...
No, I...
Yeah, no, I shouldn't even ask.
No, 100%.
People are definitely gonna judge me if I wear this in
public.
But I'll be free, though.
All right, look at this, guys.
This is a real...
These are real.
These are real shoes that you can get at the Croc store
right now.
But I will be free.
They can judge me all they want.
But I'll feel free.
I will wear them proudly in public.
I know what I am.
And I am a wonderful person
With adult spending money Hey Doki just popping in to say
congrats on a 900k subs Thank you Jen, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you in public
She lost a single sub after the cracks He's like this is too
much even for me All right, but yes, so I bought these.
I bought the Squidward Crocs.
I also bought, oh, what else did I buy?
I bought a, oh, I bought Mariah Carey, all I want for
Christmas is in the store.
Oh, no, it's not possible.
It's stuck on the, it's all stuck on the shoes.
Here's $20 for you not to wear the Squidward Crocs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, so I also, Mariah Carey is in store.
I did not guys just so you guys know so you guys do I can't
aren't can't won't be more disappointed in me I did not buy
Kim Kardashian and I did not buy Mariah Carey but I did buy
all I want for Christmas is you I did buy that one that one
was very important I had to get it I also bought what else
did I buy oh my god I bought like two music tracks but I
don't remember what the other you was so important to me so
I spent in total around $60 on fortnite yesterday and I'm
gonna spend $20 more for Batman beyond I must have it I it's
actually one I feel like I personally think Batman beyond is
one of the best Batman movies they've ever it's such a
classic like the twist was so good too um i love like i
don't know like the story for it and how like you know like
when they do like uh how they do like future batman is such
like it's so good the writing is so good um it is honestly
the best i would say the best batman uh uh future future
movie ever uh no i won't spoil the movie but there is a plot
twist and it is such a no one expected the plot twist to Um,
I'm tired.
Who would have thought playing six hours of Mar-a-Ravos not
straight can make you very tired.
I was just like, I was just like, brain so tired, cannot
talk anymore.
I just wanted to, I, okay, I didn't, I didn't stream it
because I was like, it's just two to three games.
like it's just it's just two to three games you know like i
know i don't need to stream it and then i was like i kept
playing i was like all right the next game will be the last
one i'll i'll head off for the next game and i just kept
going i'm like okay i'll do like one more win if i do one
more win i'll be i'll be back to where i started and i kept
going and i was like oh wait i'm like back to where i
started but if i do one more win then i'll be up one game so
it's like after it would it wouldn't be like for nothing i
can be up points and then after i'm up one more i'm like
i'll do one more because now i'll be like up two games and i
lost the game and i'll be like okay well now i'm back to
where i started so i should do one more so i can be up one
game and i'm up one game and i'll be like okay i should do
one more and i'll be up two games and i lost two in a row
and i'm like well i'm down a game so i should do one more so
i can be back where i started and then
It's just a never, it's a never-ending cycle.
It just one more.
It never, it just never ends.
And this is why I don't gamble, because I know I'd be really
fucked.
I hate to keep stuck on that cycle.
Dragons, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on reaching 900k.
Hopefully you reach 1 million next year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can stop?
No, I cannot.
I cannot stop anytime.
a problem i i i know i have a problem i can i know i can't
stop um um but yeah i hope next year i can reach a million
subscribers it is a huge milestone next year i'm planning on
going more um i guess like focusing more on content i i i
got a little late i got really lazy i got really lazy for
half the year because i've been like so overwhelmed i guess
like overworked and overwhelmed and just like, I just wanted
to like play Marvel
It's bad, I was just like But like next year I will be More
focused More focused on making content I really want to do
videos next year Not like making like original But like
getting an editor to make To make like Like I guess like
What's the word called?
edited videos for like recaps of like maybe like long games
or long streams that i do because i've seen some people i've
seen some dragoons who aren't stream watchers but literally
just watch my shorts and they're like oh i like uh i even
during meeting greets highlights highlights that's what
they're called highlights guys guys you tell i'm really
tired i'm you can tell i'm really fucking tired i'm like
what the fuck are these called like i don't even know what
did i say what did i say before um um yeah so uh i'm so out
of it no brain is not working right now um but i do want to
do like highlight videos uh just because like i have had
dragoons come to me during meeting rates too where they're
like oh i just i watch your shorts i don't really watch your
streams um but i love watching your shorts and um and
everything and um so i figured like video highlight videos
are also like really good too for the joe's dragoons we
can't make it to uh to live streams or uh you know they
don't want to watch a playthrough in the middle of a
playthrough so you know they usually don't watch the stream
because they're like oh i came in during the middle of this
playthrough so i'm not just not gonna try and catch up to it
since it's so long so i figured doing highlights um for
those who can't uh commit to the uh the stream in general
and you know they're you know little bite-sized versions of
the videos as well yeah so i'm definitely gonna do that for
next year uh but the hardest part is just find like finding
the perfect editor and also like um because i tried i tried
to do it at first um but when i was sent the highlight like
i had i was given a highlight video and it was very long i
just didn't have time committed to like watch the video to
check on it so i was like okay i need to like outsource i
need to like wait but not outsource um i need to like oh
what's the oh my gosh i can't i need a dictionary right now
um sd thank you for the 20 gifted chips thank you thank you
um delegate yeah delegate sorry you're my dictionary right
now i can't my brain is like i forgot every word possible
like i i have done like i i do not have a frontal lobe right
now um um anyway so uh like i'm like at chat what is this
word uh so fried so i need to delegate it to one of my staff
to like watch the videos and like trust them into making
sure the video is a good video that people are interested in
watching um which because i don't have the time to watch the
highlights and like do like the the approvals for everything
uh because i want to be sure like it's entertaining and
everything too yeah i'm no i'm i'm out of it if i wanted to
do the countdown with you guys big event in my life you know
it's such a big moment 900,000 that's a lot of people
watching like subscribe to this channel and I'm really happy
about it and you know I can't do this without you guys too
like you guys are all here supporting me motivating me to
keep going there are many times where I really wanted to
quit or like just you know um like disappear and everything
just disappear from content creation but i kept going
because i love like entertaining for you guys and i love
streaming for you guys and you guys help me keep going and
everything um and this is such a big moment i want to be
have a stream dedicated to it like having like like all of
us like all the dragoons and i just celebrating such a big
moment together um and yeah and then like you know one
million subscribers soon we're a hundred thousand away from
a million subscribers And that is also a giant milestone
leading up to it.
Don't go into the light.
Billy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on 900K.
It's very difficult to grow as an Instagram, but you made
it.
A small tip about short videos.
Eight minutes plus a few seconds is a very good highlight
video link for the YouTube algorithm.
Thank you and super chat.
Thank you.
I think eight minutes is going to be really hard for my
editors.
I'm going to trust my editors to like.
to um like do whatever length they can condense it to
especially if i do like a five hour stream i feel like eight
minutes is a little too uh too short for an eight hour
stream so um whatever i think i'm just whatever works the
best in condensing a stream um The thing is, I don't want to
do parts for like a playthrough because then like, you know,
it's like part one, part two, part three.
Because I don't think that's a thing anymore either on
YouTube because I know back then people would be like 10
minutes and one second.
I don't know if you guys remember that.
Like back in the old YouTube days, especially Game Grumps,
they would just make all their videos 10 minutes and one
second and then divide it by like part one, part two, part
three.
but then they uh yeah they don't like parts anymore so they
change the algorithm and i want to do something like queso
where he just i mean queso videos aren't really edited to be
fair so um but i do want some editing going into the video
um for playthroughs because he literally just upload the
entire playthrough into like one video um so something like
that i'm thinking of because it's not like clipping whereas
you know um we're grabbing like the best moments uh just
like, you know, segments of the best moment.
I still want people who are watching the video to understand
the playthrough and what's going on in the story, even
though they can't watch the live stream.
So it's like, I guess it's like a super cut.
Yeah, like a super cut video.
Lord Corosis, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Can you check the latest Dragon Public Squad upload on
YouTube and perhaps react to it live?
A little gift from us for 900K.
I won't be able to it up on the stream because then like i'm
worried because i i don't want to accidentally like i have
to like set it up for browser stuff so like that's why like
before i stream i set everything up before then um but i
haven't set up anything to like watch something i don't want
to accidentally like click the wrong link or like
accidentally like dox myself with a browser so so that's why
i'm like super careful about it because um so i know like i
would do like incognito mode every time i open something um
if i show something on stream i make sure to have the
incognito mode for the browser so i wouldn't like
accidentally show anything that that were i might actually
dox myself or actually click on something.
I remember in the packs, I'll give an incident that happened
before, but I actually doxxed my personal email.
Because I didn't go incognito mode.
Because like, randomly I was like, oh, I wanted to like
click on something.
And it required me to sign in.
And it revealed my personal email.
And I was like, oh, fuck, okay.
So I never again, I'm like super careful.
careful now.
I'm super careful when I show anything on stream.
Yeah, it's very scary.
Oh my god.
And then like, it's so weird.
Okay, so I got like my PayPal email got revealed somewhere.
I don't know how.
But it's so weird.
So my PayPal email, because I don't use my PayPal email.
It's like a
That's unrelated to like the business email.
And then someone like, I don't know who this fucking person
is.
It's so weird.
That's been like sending me like money requests, being like,
please give me $5.
Like I almost paid for it because I was paying my invoices
to artists or like people I work with for a special like for
like projects or stuff.
And then they've been doing this the last two months.
months.
They've been sending me like, like $5 invoices and asking me
to be like, please give me money.
And I'm like, because they're like, please give me money.
I'm broke.
I'm like, how did you find this email?
How did you find this email?
And they've been doing it every month.
I would reject it.
And then the next month, they send it again.
And it's in the last three months.
I don't know how to block this guy's email.
Here's my dollars for that guy.
Season, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Net feathers, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, it's so weird.
I have no idea how they're doing how um how they're doing
it.
All right.
Let me check the all right what is this where is it oh
where's the where's the thingy oh yeah i got it oh yeah
twitter's been weird like i don't know if it's if it's just
me but oh that is so cute the shimmy shimajis bottom bottom
oh there's three different shimajis oh my god that's so cute
wait I'll link it guys I'll retweet it right now oh I love
shimajis they're so cute that is so adorable wait it's a
four sorry I can't count I'm watching the turkey fucking
kidnapping one in the browser it's like pay attention to me
why are you looking at the stream for it and then she chucks
it away and so i retweeted it guys i retweeted it guys oh
it's so cute wait there's four one two three oh my god there
is four i said i had to count i was like one two i'm tired
i'm so tired oh yeah so yeah i just remembered we also have
winter voice packs that's out right now show you guys um oh
yeah so the winter voice packs they're out right now so
originally um these the buttons they are they are limited
they are limited so we're not restocking them again um we
did add a hundred more because uh uh we were not expecting
um it to sell out so quick because it was limited edition uh
because we're not planning on uh we were too worried that we
might order too many So we are like, okay, 100, we'll add
100 more because they sold out on the first day.
But after the 100 is gone, we're not restocking after that
because we're worried about having too much stock.
Because that's what happened with the doggy shirts.
We ordered too many doggy.
We have too many doggy shirts right now.
It is bad.
I don't know.
We're trying to figure out what to do.
about it because we might have ordered too many so so um
because of that we are more mindful now how many do you have
i'm i'm not gonna say but we might have messed up in
calculation on how hot and demand a hawaiian shirt for dogs
would have been i might have i might have miscalculated on
the man they were yes the cat can wear one i have um a
dragon um actually bought one for their cat and wait i'll
show you guys a picture you know i'll chill it right now
because we we fucked up i i will take the blame i thought
they would be very popular i'll take i thought they would be
very popular so i'll take the blame unfortunately they we
might have sold like i will say i'll let you guys know we
might have sold less than 40 of them um and by less than 40
i think we might have sold less than 35
So, it's a very, I thought it was, I don't know, I was like,
I really wanted it.
So, I thought it was a cool idea, but the world just wasn't
ready for Hawaiian shirts for dogs.
Not like that.
This was, the world just was not ready for this item.
Everything else is doing great.
It's just, this item was just...
Way too specific I was not a visionary.
I just I just really wanted a Hawaiian shirt for my dog, but
Unfortunately, I was the minority when it came to that.
Yeah, oddly specific.
Yeah Wait, I was too ahead of the time Naked 36 let's go.
Yeah you know what my dog needs you can be matching with dad
what do you mean um maybe if it's a human yeah the target
demographic was unfortunately very narrow um if i want one
everyone wants one i've i've made too many very specific i i
have to think more in general i'll be like what do vtuber
fans want not what does my dog want
That was my problem.
I was like, what do I want for my dog?
That was way too specific.
I need to be like more general in regards to like, would you
be to your fans one?
What do I want?
The thing is, even when I think about like, what would I
want?
So the cross shiblets, they're doing okay.
They're doing okay.
But they were also, they're very specific.
items you know um so I just I'm getting too specific with
the items I want because not everyone has Crocs but I'm like
but I have Crocs though and that's cool I think it's funny
um but unfortunately the world isn't ready for funny the
world people are still not free yet people are still not
free of crocs are easier to maintain than a damn bed that is
also true no whimsy in this world funny does not equal
profit sometimes i will have to admit i understand now why a
lot of corpos just automatically go towards acrylic stands
because everyone wants acrylic stands but not everyone wants
a Hawaiian shirt for dogs I under there's no there's no way
you can fuck up an acrylic stand but I'm still coming up
with good I I've like pivoted my ideas to be more like what
do vtuber fans want instead of like what do I want because I
realize sometimes the things might not be very profitable
because I have some really dumb ideas I think it's funny as
a merch but doesn't necessarily mean that I will sell enough
so that's my like 26 like for 2026 um I'm just like the
people were just I'm just too ahead of my time
head maybe in in 50 years my items would sell more but for
this year this year was just not it when it comes to like
the funny ideas I have um um but yeah 2026 the merch that
we're going for 2026 uh is definitely much more let's see I
would say what's the word 2026 for merch would be more
accessible it'll be it'll be more accessible to two dragoons
a bit more mainstream but I won't be like obviously like I'm
not gonna do like you know spamming acrylic stands because I
personally think like um you know acrylic stands they're
like you know they're nice to display and collect but I do
want to have more fun things included for you guys like
especially some stuff that is like more usable too you can
use as well so I am trying to like balance between the two
yeah it does kind of get old so I'm trying to like balance
between the two with like you know uh uh yeah more practical
merch too more practical merch as well uh but that's for
that's 2026 we're we're looking in the i have have a couple
of merch design being designed and going through like the
manufacturing process of like um well it's not actually
being like the drafting phase of it um and i think you guys
are gonna like it if not i might have a lot of them in stock
and if not i have failed yet again i am i am not what's the
word i am not Hip with the kids.
I don't understand.
I thought I was relatable.
It's a process.
I thought I was relatable, guys.
I don't understand.
What do you mean there's not enough dogs in the world?
I'm not hip anymore.
It's a learning experience.
Yes, it's a learning.
It was just a Hawaiian shirt for dogs.
That one was my biggest mistake.
It was funny, though.
It was creative, and it was funny.
But I will say that was my biggest mistake when it came to
VTuber merch.
Caskey, Cas, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Affordable Dookie Bird Ramsticks.
Thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm that one.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, just ordered that pet shirt.
My bad.
I was waiting for Payday to get the Hawaiian dog shirt and
then forgot about it.
Can we get pet collars next?
Guys, I can't, I can't do another bad investment.
I have way too many Hawaiian dog shirts.
We can't do this again.
I don't think we have enough dogs.
I,
um season thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
guess you guys aren't ready for that yet but your kids are
gonna love it thank you with a super chat thank you thank
you um make a cat shirt okay the hawaiian shirt is
interchangeable with cats you can put the shirt on your cat
i just don't know if your cat's gonna like it but you can
put it on your cat um uh morning thank you welcome to tomato
farm welcome welcome I think, though, I think if the
Hawaiian shirts was in pet stores, it'd go crazy.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think, I think if I could get these shirts in a store,
people will buy.
I just need to, I don't know, I don't know if PetSmart would
allow me.
What if I just, like, go to, like, those, like, pet
conventions to sell my shirt?
at a booth i think if i did that maybe i can actually get
get rid of the stock
yeah sell them at a flea market that's true i could do that
i should no i shouldn't do that i shouldn't personally do
that but someone should um in my in my management team
someone should do that okay i think phone cases are only if
you're like I think phone cases will have to be done with a
collab with a phone case company because there's so There's
too many different phones now There's way too many iPhones
and there's way too many like A brands for phones now with
different look like Different shapes and different camera
placements and everything That's why people would collab
with a phone case company because they have a machine That
just prints them one by one so they get an order blank case
and then just print it on and everything
Yeah, unless you use the you don't do what Pokemon does
where they have like the the The universal phone cases where
it's literally like a little binder thing, but I hate those
I'm I used to I I remember buying them for the first time
because I love the design and I tried it once and like I
hated using I hated using it because it's like it's just so
inefficient.
It feels weird in my hat.
Yeah, it's like a Like, it feels, like, weird in my hand,
and it's so inconvenient.
Because I gotta flip it.
I don't want to flip it.
I just want to, like, get my phone out and then use it.
I want to make those, uh, those card stickers.
Like, uh, but then I'm worried if I do it for, like, credit
cards, like, you know, those credit card stickers where you
can, like, put a sticker on top of your credit card, and
then it's, like, customized?
your card if i do that they're just like um is this a fake
card like yeah i don't know i feel like if if you put i feel
like people like i feel like random places are gonna start
rejecting your card because when they see it they'll just be
like what the
we got a tap to pay but what if you're like in a place that
doesn't have tap and then they like they like you have to
give them the card and they look at the card and be like no
i don't want to be like i don't want to be responsible with
that if you're stranded somewhere in the middle of nowhere
uh because you're in like the countryside and uh you try to
give them the card to yeah you try to pay for something with
your card but you put a fucking a uh dragon sticker on top
of it and then they look at the card and be like are you
fucking with me like we don't accept this are you trying to
scam me and then now you're stuck in the middle of nowhere
uh with no money or any like and your phone is dead and
you're like fuck you toky bird i bought your credit card
sticker and now i can't go home and then like you gotta stay
you gotta sleep on the side and then hope that your family
and friends filed a missing persons report and
missing person report and then they're like this is the last
place like this is the last place their phone um their phone
told like said they were at um and this is kidding i just
don't want to be liable i i don't want to be liable for
anything and
then and then you have to you have to sleep out on the
streets for like 24 hours maybe longer because you don't
know because i don't know if your family or friends care
enough to file a missing person report they'll just be like
they're on a road trip what if you told them you were going
on a road trip so they expected you to be gone for several
days so then you're out there in the middle of nowhere um
with no money no phone no way to communicate with all your
loved ones uh because you told them you were going on
I think you thought too hard about this.
Maybe a wallet would be better.
Oh yeah, no, but forgot about the food part.
New Fear Sephalum chapter.
Doki, you might be overthinking this.
But it's a sticker.
You can just peel it off.
But what if what if that's like You peel off the sticker But
the part that you need That would like work in the card Was
like Was fucked up like you know how the sticker was too
sticky And it's stuck on the card So you have to scratch on
it And after you scratch on it You end up accidentally
scratching the strip Or the chip off
Because you're desperate You're so desperate I gotta get the
sticker off and then And then you were You were too
aggressive with the sticker And now your card is unusable
No sticker is damaging the chip Bro
Uh Good thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you
Okay but can I just say something on this Because I used one
for real the past It's by as long as you have a different
cuts to accommodate different cards As long as the numbers
show.
Thank you, the super chat code.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's a...
Wait, how many different cards are there?
As long as...
But, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, that's top confessional piggy bank, but it's Doki
asking for super chats and you confess your sins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, there's a lot.
Okay, maybe we won't be doing credit card skins, guys.
Maybe...
There are more than one type of cards.
What do you mean?
There's more than one...
Oh my god.
Why isn't it universal?
Yes, thank you for magenta, super, thank you, thank you.
Today is my 30th birthday.
Happy to see 900k doki.
I'll be on dedicated fan and never miss your future live
streams.
Thank you for the akha magenta, super, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear yas happy birthday to you yeah happy
birthday
jacquard thank you thank you the fact yoki brought the
scenario in such a high detail that means it's happening
somewhere in the multiverse to an unlucky alternate dragon
thank you the super chat thank you thank you okay but then
what if a dragon buys the wrong sticker for their card and
then my scenario is gonna happen because they put it on the
card, but it covers up the things that shouldn't be covered
because they bought the wrong and then I will be, and it'll
be like, curse you, don't keep bird.
Why didn't you explain more clearly what sticker goes with
what card?
And then I will feel bad.
Please, it's an optional purchase.
and then I'll create another I'll create an auntie guys I'll
create I'll say that I think like the most passionate auntie
would be a would would be a fan would be an ex fan I will
say that I think like um a lot of like like a lot of like
really passionate people who like hate a specific thing will
be a former fan of the thing yeah they are usually the
biggest hated and i don't want that
it's a it's a tale as old as time
yeah the greatest hate comes from former love and then you
pay too much for shipping for a fucking sticker exactly
matcha thank you the super chat thank you thank you
oh yeah anyway i do have some fun stuff coming for 2026 uh a
lot of really fun things 2026 would be pretty interesting um
like i said like um a lot of stuff planned for the first
half of the year oh my god i'm gonna be so tired for like
i'm gonna be oh well i'm definitely gonna be really tired
for next week because next week the next week and a half the
the last stretch of 2025 uh there's gonna be a special new
year stream um on the 31st for psc countdown there's gonna
be a special psc countdown for new years um um that i've
been planning for a while uh the project has been in the
works for the new year thing for like half a year so it's
gonna be very exciting um i hope you guys will this one is
the one that i'm super looking forward to the most um the
900k slash uh i will say the 900k is more special than
because i was planning on first combining the 900k
celebration with the christmas celebration but since i
realized like a lot of dragons will be spending most of your
time so a lot of dragons have a life and like me i just
stream uh a lot they might be spending their christmas with
their family and loved ones so I figured like maybe I should
do a celebration like on a day where people are more free so
the 900k celebration will be uh will be pretty fun as well
um the Christmas one was originally gonna be the 900k
celebration as well but since we're splitting it I gotta
figure out what exactly I do have something planned for
Christmas but it's more so like the gift that plan to give
you guys um but other than that i'm like thinking like oh my
gosh what what do i do
we have last land here oh man also today i only ate one meal
today because i'm saving my stomach for tomorrow for the
christmas market um because there's like i was watching like
uh tiktoks of the Christmas market and I was like oh that
food looks so good and I was like oh I gotta I gotta save my
stomach for tomorrow no you don't understand I ate before
the last year I ate before I went last year and I regret it
I was like there's so much food I wanted to eat but I was
like I couldn't I couldn't force myself to eat more I
literally had I ordered one dish and I ordered a schnitzel
and a schnitzel and and I think like a churro and then I was
full and I'm like why why did I do this I could I'm like no
I could have fit more food in my stomach
So, so not, not this time, not this time, I've learned.
Because I didn't, I've never been to a German Christmas
market before.
I didn't, like, research it or anything.
I just thought it was, oh, hey, there's a Christmas market.
I didn't realize there was food there.
So I was like, and then, but it was so good.
It looked so good.
The food looked so fucking good, too.
And I'm so sad, but not today.
Not tomorrow, actually.
Not tomorrow.
I've learned.
But they're going to be overpriced as hell.
I can feel it.
It's obviously.
It's usually a scam.
But like it's a scam that I will participate in.
It's like kind of like I don't understand that.
It's like food trucks too.
Like food trucks are like they're really like you know some
food trucks.
um um uh some food trucks they over they're overpriced as
fuck for some mediocre food but you're like i mean i'm here
they might look cool but they're just like it don't taste
good uh yeah they charge like premium shit for um uh for
something that like might not even taste that good but
you're like well they look good at least yeah like remember
when i told you guys the story how like the like they
overcharge you it's good but it's like so expensive too yeah
there's some that that's fire but overpriced as fuck i
remember i bought like a katsu sandwich at a food truck that
waited like one hour for it you guys remember like for
canada day i was like um i'm gonna go to i'm gonna go check
out this like event for canada day for a bit and then like
um and then i went there and then I waited in the fucking
food truck line for a Katsu sandwich for one hour and then I
had a stream like third like I I was like okay so I have a
stream in like um and like two and two and a two and a half
hours or was it in two hours I have a stream in two hours
and I was like surely it's not gonna take me that long to
like go to this event in cat for Canada day because the
event was like five to ten minutes away and i was like oh
i'm so hungry oh and there's food trucks there too i'm just
gonna go there hang out a little bit and then go back just
in time for my stream and i stood in line for one hour for a
fucking katsu sandwich it in fact didn't take that long and
it was good i bought more than just a katsu sandwich because
at that point i was like was in this line for what that's
their plan that was actually that's so smart now that i
think about it that's so fucking smart like you know they
make all these people line up for so fucking long and
they're like oh well now that i've been in this line for an
hour i might as well buy more than just a cashew sandwich so
i bought a cashew sandwich um the the pork cashew sandwich a
chicken sandwich and also um and also chicken nuggets and a
drink because i was like i am ordering food for the next two
days because I already lined up this lot and then I had to
wait another 30 minutes for my food to like be given to me I
had I had to wait 30 minutes for the food to be done and
then the thing is I had to um when I say like 10 to 15
minutes away it was like by Uber so Um, so like I had to
walk because like all the roads were closed off, you know,
because you know, it's like a event So they closed off all
the roads.
So I had to walk like 10 minutes And then Tokyo's no, I'm
very easy to scam that's why like I remember when I was
like, okay, okay, I'll finish the story and I'll tell you
why I'm very easy to scam Um, uh, but like I had to walk to
don't say that part um i like walked over to have to walk
like 10 extra minutes to the to find a road the open road
and had to wait for the uber because there's an event going
on ubers were very hard to get so i had to wait for the uber
and then get and then like by the time i had to wait another
15 to 20 minutes for an uber to pick me up and take me home
and and throughout all that i was just eating my chicken
nuggets i was just like walking over to the road and just
eating my chicken nuggets because i was so i was so fucking
hungry at that point anyway I'm very easy to scam I'll tell
you guys why um I'm very naive and gullible when it comes to
these things because I'll be like there's no way people will
lie like in real life so um I'll remember guys remember that
one time I told you guys like some I got an email being like
uh I remember exactly what the email was but um like
something about how like oh you use this song uh we are
gonna sue you if you don't like uh reply back or some shit
and i couldn't tell if it was legit or not and i was like
when did i use an illegal song but anyway um when i was
younger when i was in middle school um when i was in middle
school um we went to like this city in china like we
traveled like you know i was in china for international
school and um and and uh and we were traveling to a
different city um and it was like a village that's like but
it was like a tourist village so it was like a traditional
chinese village um that was also a tourist trap so uh
because there would be like boat rides and stuff to see the
cranes and everything and stuff like that and so i wanted to
buy a some souvenirs for my parents um um because back then
i loved souvenirs and stuff for like gifts for my family and
my for my relatives so i went to a shop i went to a random
shop uh with my one of my friends uh she's korean um this is
very important and i was like i saw i don't remember what i
saw but i think i saw a necklace and i was like oh that's so
pretty i want this and then like they set the price and i
like for those who know like i was like they set the price.
I was like, okay.
I instantly went like, okay.
Like, no hesitation.
And then my friend was like, what the fuck are you doing,
Doki?
I was like, what?
She gave me the price.
It seemed fine.
And then she was like, you're supposed to negotiate.
You're supposed to bargain.
And I'm like, what?
But that's rude.
You're supposed to haggle.
and i'm like i was like that's rude that's shouldn't the
price be final and then you can do and and then my friend
was like was like let me haggle for you she's like okay i'm
haggling and then she she brought the price down like 70 or
some shit i'm like wait but how would she make profit I was
like are you sure I'm like I'm okay with paying the price
she's not gonna make money I was like are you sure though oh
but what if I don't want to scam her literally right now she
was the lady was trying to scam me like I was way too
trusting I still am.
Addis, thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
This is the final price.
Don't you Super Chat can't go higher than $5.
Thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
So, yeah, so I'd never haggle, by the way.
I don't haggle.
I just end up feeling really bad because I'm like, oh, what
if I...
Oh, that's so rude, haggling.
um um anyway so yeah no and then there are other times oh my
god recently recently i got a i was so scared because i was
getting these calls and emails being like you didn't pay
your phone bill um and like they had my name and like my old
address and i was like and it was like a legal like they
send me a legal document being like you did we're gonna you
better pay this x amount of money or we're gonna sue you
like it was like a debt collection lawyer like uh lawyer
firm and i was like what but and i checked my i checked my
um um i used tellus so i checked my tellus account And I was
just like, but it's paid.
I was so confused.
And then they like, they like send me like, this is a fine.
They sent me like several emails being like, this is the
final notice.
You better pay up.
And it was like $2,000.
And I was like so fucking confused because I emailed it.
I like, I like Googled their thing.
And they were like, it was like a lawyer firm.
And then like people and I Googled like there was a Reddit
about it being like, I can't tell if like I got received and
there was only one Reddit forum page about it and um and and
then I was so confused I was like and I was like do I pay
for this oh my god am I committing a crime about to pay
because I was like oh my god I didn't pay my bills my old
place like where I used to live to a place like like five
years ago and I forgot to cancel What if I forgot to cancel
my phone bill five years ago?
And I was like, I was about, and then like, I was telling my
manager about this, and my manager was like, please call.
My manager was like, please call the phone company.
Do not pay the bill.
Please call the phone company.
And then so I was like, are you sure?
They sent me a final notice, and it's due today.
and and and i like also like i didn't want to call them
because i had to wait like 30 minutes on hold i have too
much ptsd of being on hold uh and and they're like and then
they kept like redirecting me too they redirected me like
three times because they're like well we can't help you we
gotta go contact this you gotta we gotta redirect you to
this person because like this person will be in charge of
and then they're like oh we gotta redirect you to the other
person because this person is actually in charge of this
anyway we got redirected three times and all three times i
have to give them my number give them my account information
and everything and then finally on the last person they're
like um i am checking your account right now that's
associated with the address that this this lawyer firm is uh
claiming um and you don't owe any money for this address
like the place I used to live five years ago um and like I'm
like oh okay it was a scam it's I was like oh thank god it
was a scam so by the way they're still emailing me about a
final notice it's been like I think it's been like two
months now and I've been I've had like five different final
notice emails I have yet I don't know when is the last
actual notice I
yeah i i i don't know which one is the final final notice uh
slide thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy
holidays thank you happy holidays i see you too uh harm
think it was super chat thank you thank you please call the
police thank you give the super chat thank you thank you um
they do call me too i should block them as well blocked them
at first because i got scared i was like if i blocked them
am i committing a crime i was like i'm like oh my god what
if they're real what if what if the rcmp come over what if
the mountain police comes over and knocks on my door take me
away because i i didn't pay my debts
yeah one of the five percent chats are actually real
we heard you didn't pay your phone bill
oh yeah that's the life of dokeybird i was a very sheltered
child i'm surprised i was able to To survive this long The
life of the bird
How are you alive?
Boy,
thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Blocking
someone's knockout I'm waking up in the morning To help your
dad make moonshine Maybe if you're caught Thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you Now I'm a little less
sheltered, guys.
Yay!
Oh, but it was fun.
It was fun doing the little countdown with you guys and just
hanging out with everyone.
I had a great time, Dragons.
Oh my gosh.
I hope 2026 will be an even better and fun year for all of
us.
I was running out on themes today, but I hope you guys still
enjoyed today's stream.
yeah the countdown that i didn't know i got scared okay we
were like we were like stuck on 899 000 for like four days
so i didn't i didn't want to risk it i was like what if if i
do a countdown too early i have to wait like like i'll be
streaming for five plus hours i was just like thinking like
Like, um, what if, like, I have to wait, like, five plus
hours, like, to get, like, a hundred, a hundred subscribers?
I didn't want to risk it.
I was like, I gotta, gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure.
Like, it won't be a very, very long stream.
Say, Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Hey, guys.
All right, I'm gonna head off now.
Thank you all for coming to the countdown.
Like I said, I thought it was, you know, such a big moment
in our career.
I like to say art, but I think you guys are part of my
career.
You know, I can't have a career without my dragoons here
supporting me.
And I want to, you know, I want to like celebrate this
together with my dragoons, you know?
See that 900,000 together as a community.
So thank you all for coming to do the countdown and hang out
with us.
me and everything um i hope we have a great end uh of the
year for 2025 together um and uh have like um lots of fun
memories uh to um to cap off 2025 uh anyway guys i'm gonna
head off now as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if You
sell for me?
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
I won't be streaming tomorrow.
Maybe, I don't know, maybe if I get work done.
I keep like, be like, okay, if I get my work done, I'll
stream Rivals on Twitch.
But then I always forget to get work done.
I somehow, somehow, always, the last couple of days, don't
get the work done.
Because I somehow be like, well, if I'm not going to get the
work done, I'll just play like two to three games of Rivals.
said and then somehow it always ends up not being two or
three games of rivals it's a problem it really is a problem
and that is why i do not gamble i do not gamble real money
because i know i know that um i know that it does it will
work on me it will it will work on me um hey guys i'm gonna
head off now goodbye bye everyone i hope you guys have a
wonderful night and a wonderful monday tomorrow hi everyone
as always everybody say hi i'm gonna say i'm gonna say one
more time as always everybody stay hydrated posture can i
move around to get that blood flowing can you say it for me
head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye